this is my first example you've already
started to draw this I'm not going to
read through it because I have it right
here but in addition to that what I want
to do is help us work out the surface
area accurately by pulling out the parts
of the Nets then I'm gonna need to
evaluate so it's that would be easy part
there's the base there there's the
rectangular base at the bottom and it's
10 by 18 so you can see I guess I'll
call this my 10 and this is my and you
can also see on this front sort of face
I have a thinner triangle here
now I take that back that's the wider
joint over here I have a thinner
triangle 10 across 15 up so I'm going to
label this 10 on the base it attaches
here if I wanted to and then I've got
this height here which is 15 with me in
the same way I've got a wider triangle
this one has a base of 18 and it's going
on how part 13 okay I've got everything
set up so now I'm gonna say total
surface area and I've got it all laid
out so I can say area of a rectangle 18
by 10 now I've talked about this before
I know the triangle formula has a half
in it and you're about to double it so
it's tempting to just not write those at
all but I'd encourage you to write them
because the 2 and the half are
meaningful okay they actually tell you
what is going on and they tell me you
know
so I've got two triangles a video and
it's half space to type you agree like
so and then I'm gonna rehearse it for
the final Pam
and now if you want you could
immediately turn to your calculator for
this other there suggests as much as
possible I don't know if Nathan an
injury this is their attention but I'll
do what Nick and Andrew are doing and if
you can calculate some things in your
head I know you don't have to but I
don't know if you guys know when
astronauts go into space because up in
space they're not feeling the experience
there are no experience in gravity all
of their muscles the muscles you're
using right now to sit up under gravity
the muscles I'm using to stand up under
gravity you don't have to use them does
anyone know what happens to his muscles
when you just lock using them they
degrade they go away way cool it has a
man
it's full of attributes a lot of the
pretty thing astronauts come back to
spacing if they haven't exercised enough
this it's so hard for them to actually
stand up in their hearts can't even pump
their blood up and down your brain is
exactly the same so if you look at this
and reach for your calculator that's a
bad idea you are making your brain
atrophy we can all do that without
punching any buttons in now to in that
half we know they're going to combine
and this again is just a 13 by 18 all
right now we're sort of stretching it I
think I've already worked out with my
nose
it's already got it three hundred and
something right 320 can someone
Confed that movie turned a thankful
now that the seconds yeah yes no and so
now you can adebola three that's going
to be 564 right what's the unit
millimeters swept okay
now just put your pens down for a second
I'll show you the second example but I'm
going to show it on here and then I'm
gonna leave it up so you will be able to
catch up in a second I just want you to
watch what's going on because this one's
tricky have a look at the second
triangle pyramid and see how it differs
from the first how is the second pyramid
different name for a second okay the
lodge what do you reckon okay so they've
given you well you can just count the
number of measurements you've got before
over here I've got three over there okay
significantly what measurement is that I
have over here that I didn't have over
here yes
yeah that's right it's smack bang from
the top and it goes straight down okay
in fact is something kind of implied
there that I want all of you to include
you might maybe your bestie okay it's
the perpendicular height see these ones
they're kind of leaning over this
slanted okay whereas this one's not so
when you draw this diagram I want you
watch this carefully okay when you draw
this diagram and drawing it is so
important because of what you're about
to add on to PR you will need to add
some constructions so you can turn this
problem into this one okay think about
it for instance have a look at this this
space over here let's choose a better
color see this space over here pardon my
messy coloring okay so you see it right
that face over there is like this guy's
yes my eyes look taller but you need
this right here except I don't have it
do you see where it is it's kind of over
here now I don't have it in there so
here's what I'm gonna have to need to
add into my diagram so I can find out
what this height is here the
constructions watch I'm gonna add in a
horizontal line over here and this is
the hi I'm after now I know it looks a
little bit weird because you've got
perspective on this that doesn't look
very right angle ish but it is they have
a look how am I going to get to this
length over here what information in the
diagram can I use to help me izabel
anything
yeah good so I've got this sixteen I
don't know what this is just yet but I
can find out very easily it's it's half
of sixty right because as I said it's
right in the middle of the pyramid so
therefore I can say that's thirty dump
it and you can go ahead and use my
baggers let's see here
16:30 if you think about this is it
common factor between these two right
what's the common factor that's eight
that's 15 some of you might recognize
it's fairly common again to see that
number there right it's like three four
five but it's another fuel long so now
I've got that what's this pink triangle
that I've got here what's the one of the
dimensions on the base of 24 hi 217 are
you okay with that is you're gonna add
those on in exactly the same way
it's great if you know you can see I can
put a light over here
and you can see I've got the front face
question are you records I've done with
it that's right so let's go back a
little bit I'll put that color in back
wait a second
good pickup now once you've got that hi
there
I'm gonna do the same thing to work out
this front facing one can you see 16
here what's this length well half of 24
which is 12 so you've got 12 16 if you
need to match the numbers I'm pretty
sure this is another 3 4 5
why don't we try again right so I think
that makes this one 20 okay and you can
go ahead and you can do Pythagoras
probably to check it out now put all my
numbers I've turned that pyramid into
this one and you can go and do the rest
does that make sense no 34 okay I'll do
it I'll do a long ways for you just in
case you're wondering let's call this h4
hypotenuse okay with that H squared
equals 16 squared plus 30 square do you
agree yeah 256 plus 900
you can go ahead and put the square root
button on your calculator I'm pretty
sure